لذا كانت ميا سيريو البالغة من العمر 11 عامًا في
الفصل الدراسي في الصف الرابع لدرجة أننا
سمعنا الكثير عنها مع الآنسة
جارسيا وميليس ميريليس ، وقالت إنهم كانوا يشاهدون
ليلو وستيتش لأنهم
انتهوا من نهاية العام الدراسي.
قالت إن أحد معلميها
تلقى بريدًا إلكترونيًا يفيد بوجود مطلق نار
في المبنى وذهب إلى الباب
وكان هناك
مباشرة وقاموا بالتواصل البصري
مع الفريق
، ثم أطلق النار على النافذة في  الباب
أم ثم قالت ميا إن الأمر
حدث بسرعة شديدة لدرجة أنه دعم المعلم في
الفصل الدراسي
، وقام بالتواصل بالعين مع المعلم
مرة أخرى ونظر إليها في عينها
وقال ليلة سعيدة ثم أطلق عليها النار
وقتلها ، قال حسنًا  ليلة قبل أن أطلق النار
عليها ليلة سعيدة ثم حدث ذلك
بسرعة كبيرة بعد ذلك ، كما
بدأ إطلاق النار المفتوح في الفصل ،
وضرب الكثير من أصدقاء ميا
في تلك المرحلة ، أصيبت ميا بشظايا
من الرصاص.  يمكنك حتى رؤيتهم
بالأمس ، أعني على ظهرها على كتفيها
مؤخرة رأسها ، ثم قالت إنها ذهبت إلى
الفصل الدراسي المجاور ، لذلك ذهب
عبر هذا الباب إلى
الفصل الدراسي المجاور وفي تلك المرحلة كان بإمكان ميا
سماع صراخها.  سمعت الكثير من
إطلاق النار
، ثم قالت إنها سمعت موسيقى
تعتقد أنها كانت من قبل مسلح
، بدأ في تفجير الموسيقى الحزينة
وسألتها مثل ما هو
نوع الموسيقى وماذا
تقصد بذلك وقالت  لقد قالت للتو أن الأمر
بدا
وكأنني أريد أن يموت الناس موسيقى
، قالت إنها سمعت الموسيقى ، قالت إنها
بدت وكأنني أريد أن يموت الناس موسيقى
ما فعلته ميا بعد
ذلك ، لذا كان لديها صديقة
بجوارها كانت متأكدة أنها ماتت بالفعل
كانت مستلقية على الأرض
تنزف
، ووضعت يديها
في دماء صديقتها
ثم تلطختها وقالت
إنها تريد أن
تبدو وكأنها ميتة كانت خائفة من
أن المسلح كان ذاهبًا إلى  عد  مرر
عبر هذا الباب المجاور مرة أخرى إلى
غرفة الصف
وأرادت أن تكون قادرة على اللعب
ميتًا
، أخبرتك أيضًا أنها اتصلت بـ 9-1-1
نعم ، لذا بعد أن لطخت
الدم في جميع أنحاء جسدها ذهبت هي وصديقتها
و  تمكنوا من إزالة الهاتف
من أحد المعلمين الذين
قُتلوا بالفعل واتصلوا بالرقم 9-1-1
وكانوا في الواقع قادرين على الاتصال
بالمرسل وتحدثت إلى
المرسل لفترة وجيزة
وأخبرتهم بما  كانت مستمرة في الداخل وظلت ميا
تقول لي إنها استمرت في القول
إننا في مشكلة نحن في ورطة مثل من
فضلك تعال من فضلك تعال نحن في ورطة